good evening and welcome to fox news
primetime i'm trey gowdy
you know we've had 46 presidencies with
45
different individuals holding that
office grover cleveland you may recall
was president twice but not
consecutively i think if we were to do
the math
something like 545 million people
have lived in this country since we
began as a country
45 have become president
what do you think when you think of
those 45
individuals we have called president how
many do you think did a good job
what do we want in a leader do we even
expect the president to be a leader
do we want leaders who will tell us what
we want to hear do we want leaders who
will tell us the truth
even if it's not what we want to hear
there are some consensus that we like
george washington
probably the same with john adams and
thomas jefferson i've always admired
abraham lincoln in large part because of
everything he overcame the failures the
self-doubt
he overcame it to lead us during the
most divisive time in our country's
history
lincoln a government of the people
by the people for the people
i liked ronald reagan because he was
hopeful he also lost
he lost the nomination and came back to
become one of the more popular
presidents
we've ever had my grandmother spoke
highly of franklin roosevelt
americans still mourn what could have
been
with john f kennedy what do we
want and expect from our leaders and if
we can't name any presidents we like
admire and respect is that their fault
or is it our fault in the course of my
lifetime only two presidents have
received more than 55 percent of the
popular vote only two that i can find
and during the course of my lifetime i
count five people
elected president with less than 50
percent
of the popular vote so with my math is
correct
only two people have been elected
president in my lifetime with more than
55 percent of the popular vote while
five have been elected president with
less than
half of the popular vote i mean there
have been more impeachments in my
lifetime
than landslide presidential winners
what would it take for us to find
someone that perhaps
70 percent of us could rally around
what would it take to find a woman or a
man who really created consensus in our
country a mandate
if you will i do wonder if the current
state of the media and our country would
even allow that
you know the media seemed to view their
job as taking down whoever was just
elected
there's a difference between
accountability and what we have now
which is just creating and profiting
from discord
but if we're an exceptional country
shouldn't we have
exceptional leaders how many of our
presidents would you describe
as exceptional leaders which forces us
to ask
what do we want a leader what are we
looking for i want leaders who are
educated formally and
informally and have a thirst for even
more knowledge
i want leaders to acknowledge something
called the truth and pursue it
relentlessly
i want leaders who are fair leaders who
bring
others along with them leaders who serve
something bigger than their own
ambition leaders who are capable of both
compassion
and discipline and wise enough to know
the difference
but i don't have the answers i may not
even know the right questions to ask
but if we're an exceptional people we
should have
exceptional leaders and we have to
identify those women and men
encourage them be realistic about them
most of all we have to demand them
and believe that we deserve them